you mentioned your correspondent mention
uh the the agreement with the
Philippines just to be clear those are
not new bases those are access to
Philippine bases uh the Philippines have
a Provisions in their constitution not
to have foreign military forces based on
their soil but make no mistake Manila
and the Philippines wants the United
States there Japan wants the United
States there Australia wants the United
States there South Korea wants the
United States there Taiwan wants the
United States there so I think this is
you know I mean we we have to be
clear-eyed about what's what's really
going on here and there's an increasing
threat I mean you may have reported
about this a senior U.S Air Force
General uh said the other day that he
thought a war over Taiwan could break
out in 2025. I personally have no idea I
don't think XI jinping's probably made
his own mind up but that gives a sense
of the the looming Peril that we face
in your estimation and uh experience why
do you think China would deploy this
balloon when it's extremely likely that
it would be spotted
it is puzzling I have to I have to
confess because I mean if they've been
willing to allow you know Xi Jinping to
meet with secretary blinken who's not
his his peer in the ranking order
um you know it's quite a it's quite a
quite a thing to have that be be
canceled
um I think the best explanation is
probably that they were trying to test
the limits and provoke I mean it's not
impossible that it was by mistake but I
think it's very unlikely I mean there
was another such balloon that's over
that's been spotted over Central America
so I mean and you know I mean this is a
centrally controlled party state where
the military is supported into the party
it's very unlikely to me that somebody
would make this kind of mistake I think
the jury's out about what they were
doing I think they are trying to provoke
us and trying to test our limits and you
see this all around and in fact a lot of
this hasn't been reported I think that
tends not to get get leaked out but it's
but it's happening
um you know in Asia in particular but
here we see it uh over the United States
I mean about a year and a half ago the
Chinese tested Hypersonic systems and
and elements of a fractional orbital
bombardment system it's basically a
missile launcher you would put in space
that tells you about the kind of
aspirations they have and they have for
their military
but what you're saying is that it's a
possibility that the balloon could have
been deployed purely for meteorological
uh reasons
no I don't I know I'm sorry I don't
think there's any real chance I mean
look there's there's there's a remote
possibility anything's possible it could
be a floating circus balloon you know
what I mean like I haven't seen it up
close but I think the chances that it's
a meteorological balloon are vanishingly
small I think it's almost certainly an
intelligence gathering platform what's
what is not entirely impossible is that
it was somehow mistaken or you know at a
lower level but I would put that below
10 myself it's not impossible the
chances of weather balloon are probably
below one percent
okay I'll Bridge Kobe thank you very
much for sharing your expertise with uh
Salvage Colby former Pentagon official
let's uh go back to Mark our
correspondent who's standing by we're
just looking at those pictures of the
Jets alongside uh the balloon earlier on
this is a replay of what took on
I'm just hearing that we do have footage
of the moment the balloon was shot let's
look at that
we think it's already been shot at this
point that we're seeing I think it's
actually starting to descend so it has
already been shot at this point there
wasn't an obvious moment of uh impact
but I think it is starting to descend
make that descent into the water
Mark Stone's still standing by for us
Mark I think this is about to show the
the moment of impact but it's not I'm
not sure that it's going to be very
clear
yes exactly because the missiles fired
from those jets are obviously much
smaller than the Jets themselves and the
missiles might not give a vapor trail in
the same way but you can see quite
clearly that what was at the beginning
of that video a very clear round balloon
then deflates and as you can see there
is beginning to to descend so this was
the moment of impact two Jets it seems
firing their missiles at relatively
close range about 50 000 feet
um about that's ten thousand or so feet
above the highest commercial Jets
um making the decision to to take it
down over water now we have had a
statement in the last couple of minutes
from the U.S defense secretary Lloyd
Austin uh I'll go through it with you
because it's quite a lot in it it says
this afternoon at the direction of
President Biden U.S fighter aircraft
assigned to the U.S Northern command
successfully brought down the High
Altitude surveillance balloon launched
by and belonging to the People's
Republic of China over the water off the
coast of South Carolina in U.S airspace
the balloon which was being used by the
uprc in an attempt to surveil strategic
sites in the continental United States
was brought down above U.S territorial
waters on Wednesday President Biden gave
his authorization to take down the
balloon as soon as the mission was
accomplished without undue risk to lives
under the balloon's path so a reference
there to a couple of interesting things
they absolutely are of the view that
this was being used by the Chinese to
spy they also say that President Biden
had made the decision back on Wednesday
to shoot it down but they needed to wait
until it was over the ocean and not over
land because of the risk it could cause
to the public we heard the other day too
that they they believed in the Pentagon
that it wasn't actually able to uh to
get much in the way of intelligence and
I imagine the air the military
installations over which it was flying
were probably told to to not do what
they might otherwise be doing in case
anything could be picked up now this
statement interestingly also talks about
Canada being involved this action was
taken in coordination and with the full
support of the Canadian government and
we thank Canada for its contribution to
tracking an analysis to the balloon
through NORAD as it transited North
America we know of course that the
balloon went over Alaska then crossed
into into Canadian airspace and then
came down into Montana so the Canadians
according to the defense secretary were
were fully abreast of what was going on
and indeed of the fact that President
Biden was planning to have it shot down
and then at the end of Lloyd Austin's
statements um the justification as the
Americans see it for why they've done
this today Lloyd Austin says deliberate
and lawful actions today's deliberate
and lawful actions demonstrate that
President Biden and his National
Security team will always put the Safety
and Security of the American people
first while responding effectively to
the People's Republic of China's
unacceptable violation of our
sovereignty so a lengthy statement there
from Lloyd Austin describing what
happened why they did it the
justification and the fact that they
were planning to do this all along they
just needed it to be over water before
they did so and they did it in
coordination with the Canadian
government as well
we know about this second
a balloon the Pentagon apparently
acknowledged reports of a second balloon
flying over Latin America the the quote
that I'm reading is we now assess it is
another Chinese surveillance balloon
that's Brigadier General Pat Ryder said
in a statement do we know anything about
that
uh no I was in touch with uh General
Ryder earlier on today trying to get
more on that and and they have nothing
uh publicly at least um other than that
statement that it was over Latin America
we think
um over
um South America that some some area
over South America it's not clear where
one one report of it been seeing over
Colombia I think from an American
perspective it's nothing to do with them
now because that that's it's elsewhere
and we don't know whether that balloon
also crossed the United States um but it
appears that there is more than one
balloon or or there is one of them's
down as we know but there is another
balloon uh up there somewhere weather
balloons according to the Chinese
Mark the big question is what what
happens now how will China respond what
does that mean for future relations
between China and America
a big big question yeah I mean the the
there are there are two ways of looking
at this story it is it's sort of almost
comical it's it's amusing it's certainly
a story that's got everyone talking the
Chinese balloon
um but but behind that it's very very
serious and the fact that President
Biden has made a decision now to shoot
it down uh makes it all the more serious
and we don't yet know how the Chinese
will respond to that they've admitted
it's theirs they could of course have
said all along and this is not nothing
to do with us we don't know anything
about this but the fact that they've
admitted it's theirs and now the
Americans have shot it down that not
that notches things up
um significantly to a relationship which
is the most important geopolitical
relationship in the world but also one
that is really really tricky at the
moment which is why defeat the uh the
um Secretary of State Tony blinken was
going to China that was seen as a as a
real moment a real breakthrough perhaps
in this difficult relationship the
Americans called that off now and we're
wait to see to see what happens next
we're reading that when the president
was first briefed on on Tuesday he
actually wanted to shoot it down then
but was advised that it should clear
land and be over water before any
operation was undertaken but it does
speak to his determination and
no hesitation in wanting to to shoot the
balloon down
yeah I mean I imagine that the White
House would always say you know he had
no hesitation and he was always going to
shoot it down I I think that's probably
not quite true I think behind that there
would always have been different
calculations different balances that
they needed to to make in the white
house we know that they were given
options as they're known from the
Pentagon delivering different options
that the president could take and and
the the assessment from the Pentagon uh
publicly over the past few days has been
do not shoot it down while it's over
land because remember this this balloon
was carrying a payload that was the size
of three buses and so if you shoot it
down over land even in remote Montana
you can't guarantee it's not going to
hit someone and cause significant damage
and and Lloyd Austin mentions that in
his statement that um the the primary
focus is is the safety of U.S citizens
um but now that it is down uh the the
White House can present this as
something that was always their plan we
were always going to shoot it down and
maybe it was we'll never know but but
they they are presenting it as a a clear
decision made days ago they waited until
it was over water and then they did what
they said and they took it down and the
focus now Jillian will be to try and get
whatever whatever that balloon was
carrying and assess it uh and take it
apart and see what was on there
okay Mark for the moment uh we're going
to leave it there but I'm obviously
you'll stay around but I'm going to
speak now to Dr Marina mirror on a
postdoctoral researcher in the defense
studies department at King's College
London good evening to you um first of
all your reaction to What has taken
place over North Carolina today
well thank you for having me first of
all we have to see um this kind of as a
political gesture I think from China
because of the U.S foreign policy and
what has been happening in the last six
months so for the the first thing was a
disagreement
um regarding China's views on uh Russian
special military operation in Ukraine
and the fact that China didn't want to
support sanctions against Russia the
second thing
um in 2022 was the Nancy palos's visit
to Taiwan and the growing tension around
tevan and China trying to kind of show
its military prowess and conducting a
military exercise there and um in
November the U.S decided to ban the
export of semiconductors to China which
would affect Chinese economy and not
just economy but also the ability to
produce um a high tech weapon systems as
well as conduct its research in AI as a
part of the AI race and just the
beginning of this year when when the
relationship seemed to improve the U.S
has decided to to step up its military
presence in the Philippines just two
days ago and then we see this balloon
and in China could have used potentially
any other Technologies such as satellite
technology to spy on the US but it was
certainly trying to make a statement and
test the water and see how the US would
respond to this
and what is the statement do you believe
that they are trying to make
I think that China knew exactly that you
know because it's a balloon it can act
with a certain impunity in the sense and
has this plausible deniability saying
that it's a weather balloon and I think
the statement that they were trying to
make is that they are not okay with with
the U.S foreign policy and this
closeness between the US and Taiwan
because the U.S has opened factories um
staffed by Taiwanese workers to
manufacture semiconductors in the U.S so
I think it was a signal as a part of the
so-called sub-threshold Warfare which
wouldn't be enough to respond with
military force but is enough to say we
can enter your airspace and what can you
do about this right
but why would China
um
risk the visit of Anthony blink and
which was due to take place this weekend
why would they risk that going ahead
I think it was a way of a gamble because
um the Chinese saw there are two
possibilities either they didn't know
that this balloon would be detected
right before Anthony blinken's visit to
China
or they wanted to see how will the U.S
react will the visit still take place
and I think in in in inside of kind of
China's ruling Elites there is still no
um Clear Vision of how it wants to deal
with the U.S was it you know it makes
sense to improve the relationships or
continue this competition and since the
signs from the US have been negative
from the perspective of China
um I I think it was a way to Signal it
it's um gunboat diplomacy it's called
basically to signals that China is still
watching and China can indeed
um exploit the vulnerabilities that the
US have
but would you agree that the chances of
this balloon not being detected in
American airspace very very slim
well the problem is that we've had said
um issue a few years ago was a Chinese
balloons flying all over the place
including the United States and for some
reason back then they didn't make the
news so I'm wondering what is different
now was it uh supposed to get that low
so that it could be spotted from the
Earth's surface and if it was then I
would argue that it is political
signaling and if it wasn't then China
just probably wanted to gather some
intelligence
um on the United States without it
noticing so there are those two
possibilities
however it's not clear without you know
knowing what was going on in she's mind
when he made that decision to send a
balloon what exactly the the most likely
scenario here
and do you believe that shooting down
the balloon was the only option uh
before the American president
well first of all China distanced itself
and said that it's a weather balloon so
um there there would be let's say
politically saying no harm in shooting
it down and does the other thing is we
don't know what equipment that balloon
had and if it was gathering intelligence
and maybe
um tapping into different frequencies
using kind of electronic warfare
complexes
it would have stored that information I
don't know how much of it might have
been transmitted to China already but
shooting it down would ensure that
whatever is left there wouldn't get to
China and so I I think that the decision
was well Justified to wait until the
balloon is over the water and then shut
it down even if in the process you risk
of you risk it destroying potential
evidence against China yes I was going
to ask you about that how difficult will
it be to to recover any uh information
from the balloon now that it's it's
submergent in water
well I'm not sure how um resistant the
systems are is that it was equipped with
but I think it still makes sense to
retrieve them and and try to salvage
whatever there is to salvage in order on
the one hand to know what technologies
um were on board and the other thing
would be to see whether you can retrieve
any data so that you at least know
whatever was recorded and transmitted to
the Chinese authorities and what what
data did they get to see because you
know it was hovering over the nuclear
side in Montana so there is a potential
that a lot of information had been
recorded there
but what type of information would would
you expect to retrieve from this this
craft
well apart from pictures because it has
a wider aperture it might have um tried
to tap into different frequencies in
terms of you know
um radio waves and
um try to intercept communication it
could have also probed the cyber
security depending on what technology it
had and you know for some for certain uh
cyber attacks you would want to be close
to your target physically close to your
target so there are a lot of
possibilities in terms of what China
could have gathered using that balloon
and what do you think China's Next Step
will be now
well that that's a that's a very good
million dollar question right there well
I I think China will try to um take a
step back seeing the ramifications it
has caused and to try to argue that it
was indeed a weather balloon and that it
was harmless and I think you know if
China indeed didn't intend for this
balloon to be discovered as it happened
in previous years and it never made it
to the news China was hoping that it
would get away with it probably but I I
think at this stage the best course for
China is trying to somehow Salvage the
relationship and by basically by using
its thin blanket of deniability trying
to convince the United States that it
was not a malicious use of um of a
balloon to a spy on the United States
but we shall see how this unfolds
because I think
um it is important for the United States
and China to to discuss certain issues
specifically in relation to Taiwan so an
escalation right now would probably be
unwise from China's point of view
what if it were proved to be simply a a
weather balloon what what then and would
we actually ever find out if that was
the case it depends on what kind of
evidence can be recovered from that
balloon and you know it would fit well
with the story of China doing
geoengineering and you know implementing
a certain
um kind of meteorological modifiers by
2025 so this is an official Chinese
program where they want to do
um try to manipulate basically weather
for agricultural purposes as well as
military purposes obviously so they can
make a very plausible case that indeed
whatever was on that balloon was just um
as part of this program and that's why
they sent it in the first place and you
know since you cannot steer a balloon
the same way you would steer a drone or
even an airplane
they can always say that something went
wrong with the navigation and and it it
lost helium it got it got too low and it
wasn't supposed to do that but there are
so many kinds of coincidences now in
relation to that balloon that it's
improbable but if you don't have any
evidence you cannot really do anything
speaking apart from shooting it down and
you know saying that China has violated
your territorial Integrity if you cannot
prove the intention behind China's
action then there is nothing to be done
there
Dr Marina Myron thank you very much for
sharing your expertise with us thank you
thank you
well just to recap on the breaking news
the United States has brought down shot
down a suspected Chinese spy balloon
that had been floating over the country
in North Carolina the pictures that you
are seeing is just as it is making its
descent
into the water below Two fighter jets
alongside we believe that the missile
was fired from one of those which uh
brought the balloon down
100 square miles of airspace was closed
prior to the balloon being shot down and
flights were suspended at three airports
before the craft was brought down
near the Carolina coast will of course
keep you updated on any further
developments on this story throughout
the course of the evening